[Musique]
oh
alors on s'en va chez babouchka loubat
c'est comme ça que tout le monde
l'appelle au lac baïkal elle est une
légende et pour s'y rendre
on roule littéralement sur le lac qui se
transforme en autoroute de plage durant
les mois d'hiver
à 79 ans loubat s'en émerveille encore
ce sentiment de liberté l'impression
d'être seuls au monde par un des décors
naturels les plus spectaculaires de la
plaine elle chante comme ça depuis
qu'elle est toute petite à la gloire de
cette mère sacré le lac mythique qui bat
tous les records du monde
le plus ancien le plus profond et le
plus gros bassin loubet ou non qui est
tellement clair que tous les matins et
lou boy plus encore ses réserves pour la
journée à la voir et l'entendre on
aimerait croire que le lac baïkal était
invincible
pourtant il est en péril et cette fois
dit loubat c'est la faute du touriste
[Musique]
le paysage est tellement vaste qu'on a
peine à y croire mais deux millions de
vacanciers en font leur terrain de jeu
chaque année
été comme hiver elle paradis givré des
plus photogénique avec ses grottes et
stalactites
on y glisse on y boit de l'alcool le
temps d'une photo
tout semble permis sur le lac baïkal
lubbad qu'elle s'est habitué à voir les
aéroglisseurs et des camions ont
transporté les touristes juste en face
vers l'île d'olkhon mais elle y perd de
l'eau des vivres ou autre
nous avons traversée nous aussi pour
voir lille tant convoité et la vitesse
avec laquelle on développe la rive est
sidérante
compte tenu que la plupart de ces
édifices non tous qu un système d ici ça
fait déjà deux ans que l'eau n'est plus
précoce au sol des essais l'ex chef
millions aux touristes sont drôles et
badauds les nôtres c'est le far west du
gallinacé médias couvrant les une
résidente et environnementalistes qui
nous a guidés pendant une bonne partie
de notre séjour
les hôtels et les maisons de chambres au
pouce et sans contrainte sur des ondes
pourtant vulnérables autrefois pauvres
et sans avenir prometteur lille dolleren
vit désormais du tourisme étranger
[Musique]
et avec la pandémie ce sont les russes
qui la découvrent enfin et tombe sous le
charme des sites sacrés
comme ce grand rocher le rocher du cham
et saufs nous offrons un écart minime
mais pipeau food and mass effect tout
est envoûtant des couchers de soleil à
la cuisine locale du peuple gouro ni
rail canada qui était ministre dans la
région en 2009 dit que l'avenir du lac
baïkal a toujours fait l'objet de grands
débats mais pas de réglementation fait
rire personne
sauf que ça fait des années que les
scientifiques sonnent l'alarmé soit 6 à
quoi ressemble fond du lac quand il est
propre
puis quand il est si lié d'algues aux
abords des zones peuplées les niveaux
toxiques n'ont jamais été aussi élevées
et des milliers d'espèces endémiques
sont menacées comme le nerpa c'est le
seul phoque d'eau douce et c'est un des
plus grands trésors du lac michael
système consiste
[Musique]
protéger cette nature exceptionnelle des
terribles du tourisme est un devoir
existentiel pour cali
c'est grand père et arrière grand père
ont été parmi les tous premiers
scientifiques a étudié l'écosystème une
passion qu'elle a transmise sa fille
dont la musique s'inspire toujours du
territoire
c'est ce que nous dit nico et d'acheter
plus du tout d'abord car si protéger le
lac baïkal préoccupe désormais moscou
autant les résidents la façon dont le
gouvernement s'y prend est devenue la
source de tensions et de méfiance des
causes des lots et note que les mecs
comme il faut noter qu elle note fort
occupée par la maison rose que tout le
monde connaît ici est le symbole de ce
qui ne tourne pas rond
quand et les nappes l'euro va et son
mari ont acheté le terrain il ya quatre
ans c'était pour y construire cette
petite auberge familiale
on a acheté le terrain avec toutes les
permissions requises puis on nous a dit
qu'il fallait la démolir par qu'elle se
trouve dans le parc national et les nas
bancourt mais son mari n'est plus là il
est mort d'une crise cardiaque qu'elle
attribue au stress de leur combat son
cas n'est pas unique
toutes ces maisons en bordure du lac
sont aussi condamnés sous prétexte qu'il
faut réparer les erreurs du passé
l'an dernier les riverains ont manifesté
des ponts bqr terre soit revendus à des
proches du pouvoir pour accommoder le
tourisme de masse
notre ligue 1 et ses bas sv clan c'est
que peppers mani des militants entre la
corruption soupçonner les bonnes
intentions on sait jamais vraiment ce
qui se passe ici dialysés abadou eva
notait hier en séance
elle rêve d'un tourisme écologique à
l'image de l'hôtel qu'elle gère avec sa
mère
même si transporter les déchets en
camion là où peuvent être traitées leur
coûte une petite fortune chaque semaine
oui il faudra des sommes monstre pour
construire l'infrastructure et protéger
cette terre sacrée à laquelle on
s'attache rapidement avec ses légendes
ses traditions et ses chaman les grands
sages qui ont toujours le dernier mot
tous les
le tourisme est là pour rester dix
guennadi parce qu'on ne peut plus s'en
passer
la collision entre la nature et l'humain
était inévitable
la surface est lisse mais l'eau est
trouble dans ce paradis terrestre qui ne
laisse personne indifférent
[Musique]